memories are questioned Arnold gets made
of and cannibals take over the American
frontier these movies were low-key gems
but you never know it looking at their
box office draw the Keanu Reeves
Renaissance continues largely via his
John Wick movie franchise about a
beleaguered former assassin but he has
already appeared in a whole host of
great movies starring beleaguered guys
named John from Johnny Utah to John
Constantine to Don John but easily one
of the best and weirdest Johns that
Reeves has played is the titular role in
Johnny Mnemonic a much derided movie in
spite of its all-star cast it almost
single-handedly set back the cyberpunk
movement while earning Reeves a Razzy
nod for worst actor
hit me Reeves Johnny is trapped by his
circumstances he's traded in his
memories to be a data Courier his brain
is wired to receive uploads he wants to
do one big job in order to make money
and buy back the memories he's lost but
yesterday's technobabble is today's
modern age it's honestly a wonder that
Millennials haven't gravitated more
toward this movie I want to get out of
this Rat Hole I want to get online I
need a computer while a fairly low
budget is no help the Flick's biggest
flaw is perhaps that it came out about
20 years too early for your average
moviegoers to relate to with cyberpunk
subject matter
The Dark Half is based on the novel of
the same name by the spooky king of
horror Pros Stephen King definitely one
of the stranger Concepts it's the story
of a writer who has abandoned his pen
name only to find his phony Persona has
come to life with murder on its mind
while the novel had a concept seemingly
or solely perfect for the written word
the movie has one excellent attribute
that makes it a standout the late
cinematic king of horror director George
Romero The Dark Half delivers some
gruesome images up there with Romero's
best one scene in particular features a
brain tumor reacting to its removal a
scene that will make you anxious the
next time you get a headache
unfortunately the movie failed to click
with audiences it made just over 10
million dollars still the movie's worth
a watch especially with an Adept Timothy
Hutton in a double role playing both the
writer and his evil pseudonym
counterpart Dead Alive was one of the
most surprising horror films of the 90s
filmed on a shoestring budget of only 3
million dollars by Peter Jackson Dead
Alive is a gory inventive ROM about a
teenager fighting up a horde of zombies
and dealing with some nasty mother
issues too although its low budget
should have made it an easy success the
film only made 240 thousand dollars
Stateside and it would be unjustly
ignored by American audiences until
Jackson's later success prompted a
re-evaluation it might not have
connected with American audiences but
across the pond the film had a profound
influence on another young horror buff
Edgar Wright who would pay homage to the
film in his own movie shot of the Dead
even setting its influence on other
movies aside Dead Alive is electrifying
with some of the best practical effects
seen in a horror movie and a truly
Innovative use of a lawnmower
party's over
[Music]
you might think you've seen Bloody
horror movies but you've almost
certainly never seen anything quite like
Dead Alive
DreamWorks didn't know what they had in
Galaxy Quest upon its release in
December 1999 the Sci-Fi comedy about
the cast of a Star Trek type TV series
getting whisked away on a real space
adventure opened at an embarrassing
number seven for its weekend at the U.S
box office as DreamWorks co-founder
Jeffrey katzenberg would later admit to
director Dean pariso the studio bungled
the promotion of the quirky whip smart
comedy as a kid targeted adventure and
by and large failed to sell the movie to
mass audiences nevertheless the film
picked up momentum over the course of
its theatrical run eventually recouping
twice its production budget over the
course of five months maybe it's an
exaggeration to call it a box office
bomb but considering a legacy with
almost no promotion it's clear that it
could have performed so much better if
given the proper support
you guys came who wants to Grand Tour
Galaxy Quest is now a highly regarded
film in the Sci-Fi Canon boasting
career-high performances from Sigourney
Weaver Tim Allen and the late Alan
Rickman in addition to being a Charming
work in its own right Galaxy Quest also
has a special place in the hearts of
Star Trek fans who have adopted it into
their own uneven film Canon it's a film
in part about fandom itself and its
devotees honored it with a retrospective
film Never Surrender a Galaxy Quest
documentary for its 20th anniversary in
2019.
Ralph bakshi the man that made the
infamous Fritz the Cat the first
animated film to ever receive an X
rating from the MPAA combined sex and
cartoons one more time with cool world
in it a cartoonist has to resist the
sexual advances of his own creation a
doodle named Hollywood as in would do
anything while a detective Works to
prevent her from breaking down the
boundaries of reality
it can be a strange movie with a
juxtaposition of live action and
animation that looks like a Bizarro porn
parody of Who Framed Roger Rabbit but
it's a fascinating experiment audiences
weren't exactly drawn to the film and it
ended up only recouping half of its 30
million budget which isn't exactly
surprising while it likely won't turn up
on anyone's best of the 90s list anytime
soon the film is so singular in its
conception that it's worth seeing at
least once
whereas Captain America is box office
gold today in the early 90s a superhero
period piece about a handsome patriotic
hero in World War II could barely cover
its own budget The Rocketeer follows
mechanic Cliff as he becomes a hero by
donning a stylish jacket and rocket-pack
to uncover a hidden Nazi plot in
Hollywood The Rocketeer has got a
refreshing ease to the pacing in style
plus stylish design and Earnest
execution
how do I look like a hood ornament it's
easy to see why director Joe Johnston
got the chance to reinvent another
superhero decades later with Captain
America the First Avenger his Rocketeer
is a strong criminally underrated film
that just didn't really connect with
audiences it may be that the film was
released too early to tap into the now
current superhero Zeitgeist or maybe it
was ignored in favor of other Family
Fare either way the film is absolutely
worth revisiting especially with Timothy
Dalton's performance as an over-the-top
Errol flynn-esque actor while alien
might be the most well-known horror
movie that takes place in space it's far
from the only one Paul WS Anderson's
Event Horizon is a slow simmering film
that Taps into that uniquely human fear
of space as an endless empty void the
movie follows a crew investigating a
distress signal coming from the titular
spaceship which had disappeared seven
years prior what follows is a
kaleidoscope of horrifying images spooky
Latin phrases and the creeping
realization that flying millions of
miles through space doesn't put you any
farther away from hell
what happened to your eye
where we're going we won't need eyes to
see Horizon is pretty handily Anderson's
best movie combining the bloody genre
Thrills that pervade his other work with
an able cast that is able to inject the
necessary gravitas Sam Neil in
particular is absolutely terrifying as
the member of the space crew most
susceptible to the dark Whispers of the
otherworldly horror on the ship if the
Alien movies didn't completely turn you
away from space travel then Event
Horizon certainly will the late 90s were
a time of Rapid change in the animation
industry the Disney Renaissance had
revived Mass interest in animated films
but Disney alone seemed capable of
turning one into a massive hit after the
continued success of Pixar proved the
computer-driven animation was here to
stay Studios across Hollywood and Beyond
were scrambling for a direction it was
during this time that Warner Brothers
recruited animator Brad Bird to overhaul
their process with an ambitious new
feature called The Iron Giant The Iron
Giant is a masterful film on both a
technical and story level showcasing the
potential of blending traditional in
digital animation in service of spinning
a heartwarming sci-fi Twist on a classic
boy and his dog narrative accessible to
kids but textured enough for adults The
Iron Giant is just about everything you
could want from an all ages animated
Adventure film except by the time it was
finished Warner Brothers had already
given up on its feature animation
Department the financial failure of
their previous release Quest for Camelot
convinced them to get out of the
business so the Iron Giant was released
with minimal promotion and recouped a
mere 23 million dollars from its 70
million dollar budget a twist ending was
Yet to Come however as critical Acclaim
and frequent replays on Cable's Cartoon
Network helped the film find a cult
following today The Iron Giant is a
recognizable pop culture Touchstone
making cameos in Ready Player one and
Space Jam a new Legacy and is considered
one of the best animated movies perhaps
even one of the best science fiction
movies of all time the Coen Brothers had
made a successful career for themselves
with a slew of distinctive scripts while
they found plenty of success and cult
status the that doesn't mean they're
immune to failure even for one of their
best movies the HUD sucker proxy is a
biting satire of big business and
although filled with characters who talk
fast and wear sharp clothes is a loving
homage to classic feel-good movies like
Mr Deeds Goes to Town and It's a
Wonderful Life the film follows Norville
Barnes as he moves to New York from
Indiana and accidentally becomes head of
a massive company as the unknowing Patsy
for a complicated scheme to depress
stock prices
whoa as with any Coen Brothers movie the
film is packed to the brim with
memorable dialogue and likable
characters but the look of Hud sucker
was so striking that more than a few
critics and audiences felt put off and
Confused in his review Roger Ebert
called the film All Surface and no
substance but argued that it was a
pleasure to regard and well worth the
trip to the theater if nothing else
there's never been a better explanation
for why hula hoops exist Last Action
Hero has the perfect recipe for a hit
movie in the 2020s it stars Hollywood's
preeminent muscle man playing a parody
of his own stock character in a marathon
of cute cameos and gags about the tropes
of action Cinema I'll be back you did
not gonna say that did you that's what
you always say the movie starred Arnold
Schwarzenegger was directed by John
DieHard mctiernan and arrived in
theaters about 30 years too early for
modern audiences who love nothing more
than when movies shamelessly Riff on
other more familiar movies it'd likely
have been both a critical darling and a
box office hit in 1993 however Last
Action Hero was seen as a
career-threatening dud for all involved
it barely stood a chance to begin with
opening against the second weekend of
Jurassic Park which would soon unseat
E.T as the highest grossing film in U.S
history critical reception didn't do it
any favors either varieties review
dismissed it as a joyless soulless
machine of a movie and they weren't its
only haters though it would recoup its
budget internationally it seriously
underperformed at the domestic box
office and would be Schwarzenegger's
only outright flop of the 1990s in
hindsight Last Action Hero is one of the
actors better comedies one part
Terminator 2 one part Who Framed Roger
Rabbit and one part Robert Altman's the
player it's an absolute treat for fans
of 80s and 90s Hollywood XS it's joke
dense action-packed and littered with
Easter eggs for the eagle-eyed cinephile
the original Tank Girl Comics are an
energetic frenetic counterculture blast
to the eyeballs with a unique art style
by Jamie Hewlett but it was the
character of Tank Girl herself felt that
endeared the comic to fans she was rude
hyper violent and so utterly unconcerned
with other people's opinions that she
became a 90s embodiment of Riot girl
adjacent Punk depicting a comic with
such a specific visual voice and
character might have been a tall order
but the film adaptation of Tank Girl
does about as good a job as it's
possible to do with the backing of a
major Film Studio
drop something
[Music]
to start with Lori Petty is a
picture-perfect tank girl nailing the
irreverence and punk attitude of the
character the movie itself is a mishmash
tonally and is almost impossible to
defend or recommend you either get it or
walk away shaking your head the movie is
defiantly visually abrasive but loaded
with a dynamite soundtrack and a
charismatic lead
have you ever jacked in have you ever
wired tripped today filmmaker Catherine
Bigelow is best known as the first woman
to win the Academy Award for best
director as well as the Director of the
1991 classic Point Break starring Keanu
Reeves and Patrick Swayze in between
these two triumphs however Bigelow's
career was nearly tanked by the Colossal
box office failure of her 1995 cyberpunk
Noir Strange Days
written by Bigelow's ex-husband James
Cameron and occasional Martin Scorsese
collaborator Jay Cox strange days is a
stylish visceral Thriller set in a near
future in which memories can be recorded
relived and exchanged on the black
market when a scummy memory dealer
happens across a recorded memory of a
heinous crime he teams up with a
lovelorn badass to solve the case that
the police don't seem to care about
Strange Days harshly divided critics
upon its release and was a commercial
disaster winning back just short of
eight million dollars on a 42 million
dollar budget in the decades since
however the film has been rediscovered
and re-evaluated as a lost treasure of
genre Cinema and an example of some of
Bigelow's finest work as a director with
an unflinching eye and style to spare
Strange Days touches on themes of police
brutality sexual violence and the
voyeuristic spectacle of suffering all
of which are as relevant today as they
were in 1995. it also features one of
the great unsung heroines of Science
Fiction in Angela bassett's mace Mason
notoriously hard to find but
occasionally reappearing on major
streaming services strange days is worth
going out of your way to find
ravenous is a brilliant subversion of
audience expectations a horror movie as
funny as it is scary the film follows a
mid-19th century war hero exiled in the
Sierra Nevada investigating stories of a
wendigo a human given otherworldly
strength after eating the Flesh of
another man Guy Pierce shines as the
ousted Captain struggling with
survivor's guilt and the consequences of
the actions which brought him into exile
the entire cast is able to tap into the
film's tone pushing for laughs and
humorous scenes and giving weight to the
dramatic ones ultimately the film's
abiding satire of American
exceptionalism capitalism and Manifest
Destiny it's a rare film that's able to
make such subject matter work within a
horror movie structure and doubly So
within a film that's funny as well
audiences likely missed out on this
cannibalistic creme de La Creme due
mostly to a trailer that misrepresented
the tone of the movie selling it as an
awkward comedic period piece don't be
fooled though ravenous has a lot of meat
on its bones
superhero movies might not have been all
that popular in the 90s but they were at
least more popular than superhero
parodies with that in mind Mystery Men
never really had a chance still people
who slept on the film missed an
endearing superhero story with one of
the strangest casts ever assembled Ben
Stiller William H Macy Tom Waits Eddie
Izzard Paul Rubens Hank Azaria and a
Michael Bay Cameo it's a
quintessentially 90s movie complete with
a Dane Cook sighting and a music video
tie-in to smash mouth's All-Star with
the current blood of superhero movies
it's a delight watching The Misfits of
Mystery Men fumble around with their
mostly useless superpowers you can't
throw a knife sometimes
we can't use a rake sometimes
I'm not a stab man in fact many of the
jokes in the film have actually improved
with h
as frustrating as it must be for any
artist to be years ahead of their time
it must be Agony to precede their Moment
by mere months such was the case for
writer director Alex proyas his 1998
film dark city is a rain-soaked
leather-clad sci-fi thriller about a man
who learns his reality Is Not What It
Seems and that he and everyone he knows
is being manipulated by an invisible
malevolent Force
they mix and match our memories as they
see fit trying to Divine what makes us
unique if you think that sounds sort of
like 1999's the Matrix you're not the
only one the 10 people who saw dark city
in theaters also thought so as did
critic Roger Ebert dark city was dropped
into theaters in February 1998 debuting
at number four at the domestic box
office and sliding ever downward from
there barely winning back its 27 million
dollar budget just a year later The
Matrix would become a massive pop
cultural phenomenon and Hollywood action
Cinema would never again be the same
dark city would have to settle for
status as a cult classic albeit one that
Ebert recorded a rare commentary track
for its DVD
perhaps in no Universe does dark city
receive the same love and attention as
the Wachowski Masterpiece nonetheless
dark city still deserves better than
languishing in obscurity weird Moody and
distinctively 90s dark city is like a
missing tonal link between the Matrix
and Blade Runner and is worth a watch
for any science fiction devotee
after debuting as a feature director
with five consecutive hits Tim Burton
pivoted away from his usual Flights of
Fancy towards a quirky black and white
biopic saluting one of the most famously
inept filmmakers of all time Edward D
wood Jr starring Johnny Depp as the
titular o tour of schlock Ed Wood is a
terrific Showbiz comedy with tremendous
Heart Wood story or at least this
version of it fits the Tim Burton mold
perfectly painting a portrait of a man
whose quirks make him an outsider until
he seizes the opportunity to share his
uniqueness with the world unlike The
Talented Edward Scissorhands however
what makes wood unique is a total
blindness to how terrible his art really
is Ed Wood is Tim Burton's most
critically celebrated film winning
Martin Landau an Academy Award for his
supporting role as washed up horror icon
Bayla Lugosi for all it's Acclaim
however it was a clunker at the box
office recouping only about a third of
its production budget it remains
Burton's lowest grossing film by far and
he is rarely strayed from his signature
blood and Pinstripes aesthetic sense
[Music]
foreign